the biggest knock you'll hear against
the United States that America has no
culture we hear that a lot even around
this time of year they'll say we'll take
the 4th of July none of that's American
but the fireworks are Chinese the beer
and bratwurst German the pepperoni pizza
you're eating with your family that's
that's Italian America has no culture
when I hear that I think how sad that
people can take something so unique and
so beautiful and entirely miss the point
because that is America's culture see
America is a place where people come
from all different places from all
different cultures and bring the best of
it here with them while leaving all of
the baggage behind as they become an
American it's why the guy shooting up as
a Marine to go defend this country is no
more American than the shopkeeper from
Turkey who just took his citizenship
oath he's no more American than the guy
from the Ukraine who came here to coach
wrestling at a local university because
the United States is not a place based
on a people in origin it's not a place
to find by its geography or borders
America is a country founded on an ideal
an ideal that attracts people from all
different cultures to this day the ideal
that all men were created free and equal
with inalienable rights as endowed to us
by our Creator
I hear people say America has no culture
I think America's greatest asset is our
culture culture is our most fantastic
export the United States has created the
single most influential and greatest
culture this planet has ever known and
we all contribute to that culture
because we're all Americans and that's
something to be proud
[Music]